hey everybody it's Mike frerer here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control ac.
l231 do4 separate the duties of
individuals to reduce the risk of
malevolent activity without
[Music]
collusion so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's been feeling over
overwhelmed tired and alone trying to
understand all of this defs cmmc and
nist sp800 171 compliance stuff on top
of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so
checks and balances my friends uh yes
this control is all about checks and
balances or more specifically taking the
time to Define
what those checks and balances may need
to be in order to stay secure and
protected the goal with cmmc control ac.
l231 do4 separate the duties of
individuals to reduce the risk of
malevolent activity without collusion is
to force the organization to look at
what job duties exist which could
require separation in order to guarantee
information security once separation
requirements are defined the next step
is to make sure that no person's job
duties require tasks that are defined as
requiring separation so where would we
do this we'd probably do this in the job
description this control is highly
similar in nature in to accounting
controls you don't want the same person
who checks the mailbox for checks
deposits the checks and then writes the
checks to pay the bills to be the same
person ideally uh where possible because
of the ease of theft similarly cmmc
requires you to examine this reality
within your own operation so if if I was
an assessor what I would be looking for
is the following first assessment Point
determine if the duties of individuals
requiring separation are defined so
again have we defined the duties where
would we do that probably in the job
description if I was giving a sample
answer I would say something like job
descriptions are in place for all
authorized users able to access cui
those job descriptions have been written
and defined in a manner consistent with
best practices and separation of Duties
which may create a risk of malev
activity so again if if there's a job
Duty or two job duties that may be in
the same department and there's an
overlap again we've separated those
duties now next uh assessment Point
determine if responsibilities for duties
that require separation are assigned to
separate individuals right have we
actually assigned them to separate
individuals obviously microzed companies
are going to have a challenge with this
but again an assessor is going to
understand that but in most companies uh
we would give a sample answer similar to
the following each authorized user is
only granted access access to that
information which is required to
complete their currently assigned job
duties and upon completion or change in
duties uh access is modified or revoked
in accordance with it ticket requests
from the information owner really big
there now finally determine if access
privileges that enable individuals to
exercise the duties that require
separation are granted to separate
individuals uh and again a sample answer
for that one would be access privileges
are granted to each authorized user
individually at the direction of the
information system owner via it ticket
the information owner determines who is
assigned duties based on currently
assigned job duties required and that's
how we would kind of answer that so hey
if you're confused like most of the rest
of us right the good news is here at on
call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this DARS
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped in their laps like a seagull on
a sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content that we're putting out
here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button right
now to get the latest compliance content
as soon as our compliance nerds roll it
out it really helps us out lets us know
that we're doing the right things over
here now until the next compliance tip
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next
[Music]
one